you two together on the show as I said a
complete accident we don't have the
imagination to think of that but what
are the fan reactions when you two are
seen together or you're having lunch
let's say you meet up for lunch and have
lunch together do people freak out freak
out people do freak out I mean I think
what happens to me is that sometimes
they'll yell Angela and I'm like oh rain
I know them and he's like no you don't
know go Angela and then there's a paused
right and then he's like they don't know
you but they yell my name remember one
day you turn to mean you're like oh my
god they kill your name because that
must be so hard it is weird I think I
know everybody I know well I have the
same problem because I play Coe I play
Conan on TV and then I'm Conan our life
and what's weird is that it is strange
when people would be like Conan and
sometimes if I go hey hey and keep
walking you're like hey we were
roommates in college and I'm like Angela
and I'm like oh hi we're you're at the
Prix and she's like I don't know you
oh oh oh hi what do we do with that I
don't start kissing I just over share
you